last Friday in the Bahamas there was a
music festival you remember the joke I
did well I'm gonna talk about it some
more
based on the response you gave me I'm
like okay I'm gonna tell them more last
Friday in the Bahamas there was a music
festival called fire festival and this
thing was a complete disaster
the event was promoted as a luxury music
festival with tickets going for as much
as 12,000 dollars not only that fire
festival was promoted by several
celebrities including kendall Jenner
okay now there's been a rough month for
anything promoted by kendall Jenner
she had true story she had that
controversial Pepsi ad and now fire
festival those are two things that she
promoted that kind of blew up well we
looked into it we found some other
events that kendall Jenner has been
promoting why you laughing as if this is
some kind of joke I'm doing the news
these are other things kendall Jenner
has been promoting for example there's
the Mount Etna active volcano raid yeah
check this out there's the North Korea
Comedy Festival
there's this summer's Great Pacific
Garbage Patch Country Music Festival
hey check this out Fukushima's chela
yeah Oh too soon huh too soon the crowd
says I'll check the half-life and
finally just last week she was trying to
get people to fly United that I think
they think I went too far with Fukushima
chela and by doing this they can't hear
me I know
you